how are you feeling right now
i'm feeling amazing it feels so good to
be home it's so it feels so good to see
other people other than my castmates
it feels good to see my husband to see
have my phone back i have my phone back
i've been checking texts and emails for
the past like 10 hours it's been uh
quite a ride i will say that
oh i can't even imagine how are you
feeling about finishing in the final
three
i am so honored that that i actually
made it that far
to uh be truth with uh truth truthfully
speaking
i did not think i would go that far i
did not really understand the game that
well i'm not a super fan so there was a
lot of mistakes that i made along the
way and the only thing that i held true
to was the my loyalty to my alliance
giving people my word and cooking and
cleaning that's all i did i think the
cooking and cleaning kept me around for
a while just alone i'm gonna agree with
that so let me ask you let me ask you
this
if you were sitting next to either misha
or todrick in the final two
do you think you could have won
well knowing what i know now i think i
would have had a really good shot for
sure i honestly have not seen the show
yet i just got out of the house last
night really late i was doing press very
late last night i got up early this
morning to jump on with you guys so i
still have not seen the show so i don't
know what happened all i know is when i
came out on stage my cast was furious at
todrick and i was like and i didn't have
a chance to even talk to anyone i was
like what's going on or like we'll tell
you just make sure you watch the live
feed i was like what
so
i you know obviously i was the only
person that voted photograph because i
had a great relationship with them in
the house and i had i have not seen the
show and i thought it was very uh i was
very surprised that he didn't get more
votes and that misha got all the votes
but apparently i have to watch the show
so
so do you have any regrets and when it
comes to trusting todrick and misha
my reality when i was in a big brother
house was my reality i had no way of
knowing like they didn't know the cats
my customers didn't know anything until
they left the house so
i stood in my truth in my reality while
i was in the house and now that i'm out
once i watch the show
then i have to excuse me um
you know i'll deal with my new reality
but that was my life yeah
so
yes
you know it's one thing to feel that
tension from the jury and you must have
been so blindsided by that we could feel
the tension at home but
what have you learned when it comes to
the fan reaction then to todrick
i
have not had a chance to even really go
on instagram
i know
that there's a lot i know he's been
trending
um i
i'm still just coming up for air i'm
still processing
i haven't even had a chance to talk to
all of my cast mates yet you know carson
was my ride or die i can't wait to talk
to him but i literally
just
got up this morning and jumped on with
you and i have a day full of press and
later on i'm gonna watch the show for
sure yes
and get on social media and see what's
going on but uh i'm just happy to be be
home right now i'm sorry
happy to have a private bathroom
and be able to you know turn my lights
off and on and you know
be able to walk outside if i want to
how excited were for you to learn that
carson won america's favorite house
guest
oh i was so excited
carson
was a dream in that house i could not
imagine myself in the house without him
he was my ride and die he was the one
person that was the most transparent
with me we were in it until the end and
it was very difficult for me to stay in
the house honestly like i didn't even
really want to be there after you left
because i you know i was pretty it was
pretty much you know
toddrick and misha lamar and todd and
then i was kind of like a third wheel
with everyone um you know i felt very
displaced after he left yeah you know
when you look back on this experience
and i know other host guests have voiced
this but do you wish things had gone
differently with shayna
oh 100
again i have not seen the show but from
what i'm hearing
um
todrick and michael lied to us we got
duped we got big brother i don't know
what you call it but
um
i definitely if those things are true
and it looks like they are i owe her a
huge apology personal public whatever i
have to do to make that situation right
other than carson she was the other
person that i was close to she was my
roommate the whole time
and
you know again in that moment i was
doing what i thought was protecting the
alliance and definitely protecting
protecting carson because he was so
giving to both shanna and i and would
have done anything for us so as soon as
i thought he was being betrayed in any
way by her i just was not having it yeah
no i totally understand that what would
you say has surprised you the most about
playing big brother
um
[Music]
celebrities really or dirty people
people clean up after themselves
all i did was clean that house
when i tell you i understand why
celebrities have housekeepers they are
filthy people oh my god
like just not even picking up like it
was like picking up after children
that's what i learned
i love that the big takeaway would you
ever play big brother again if given the
choice
not anytime soon that's before i'll
never say never
because i did get farther than i ever
thought that i would but
not anytime soon i am so happy to be
home and um
you know i
absolutely
not anytime soon i'll just leave it
there yeah if you you know there's
another season of celebrity big brother
is there a celebrity that you personally
would love to watch try to play this
game
oh wow
uh
let me see a celebrity that i would like
to see
play the game
um
you know what it was rumored
um that tiffany pollard was going to be
on the show and i have to be honest i
was like nervous and excited for her to
be there so i think she would have been
amazing on our season so yeah i'm going
to go with tiffany oh that's a good one
now i know that you left real housewives
and uh you know you're working on other
things what's in store for you what can
we expect
oh what is not in store for me this next
chapter
has been amazing after doing celebrity
big brother i think i i think i can do
anything now like i think you can vibe
that show you can pretty much do
anything i have a movie coming out on
lifetime in march called the lock down
um so my acting career is taking off
that's what i'm really focusing on out
here in los angeles right now and also
i've been hosting um
a lot of different um
shows the real e daily pops so i've
fallen in love with that as well
and uh you know the sky's the limit i
have some other projects that i can't
really talk about my partnership this
escapes is still happening can't wait to
get back on the road and do my women
empowerment tours with them
um you know i'm open and and i'm looking
for a job so you can put that out there
as well
for employment celebrities is over i'm
looking for my next gig
yay well i can't wait to see what you're
gonna do you must feel so proud of how
you played this game and you enjoyed the
time with your family now
thank you you know i played it the only
way that i knew how to play it which was
like i really didn't know how to play it
but i knew i had to go in and just be
loyal to
you know the people that i was down with
and you know just be a woman of my word
and just um you know go to play to my
strengths which actually i love cooking
and um
you know i like keeping a clean house i
like living in a clean space so
that was it cooking cleaning and just
being a woman of my word and staying
loyal to my alliance